[Music]
hello developers are you ready for our
next session
now we're gonna hear about seven yes
seven new features that help you
simplify building modern applications so
please welcome representing the
Netherlands and he really does own five
bikes Google Cloud developer relations
engineer Vita venema
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is vitsavainma I'm a
developer
and I'm an author I wrote this book
building serverless applications with
Google Cloud run
it's a short story about the book it's
um it has a bird on a cover
it's an O'Reilly Animal book so the
O'Reilly doesn't let you pick the animal
they do that for you so it's a book
about cloud computing so yeah I got the
bird
and when I first showed this this book
to my my daughter she's five years old
see um she looks at me
dad
did you write a book about a bird
question
so I'm like
um no it's about containers running
containers in the cloud
so she looks at me puzzled
did you did you put a bird in a
container
well it's it's sweet right
another another thing I like about being
a dad is that I can make dad jokes now
yeah yeah I'd like to bring the energy
level up so what do I say to you when
there's a duck flying into you
duck
okay and I have another one so who's
from Bavaria
I like to say hands okay I learned a
very great dad joke yesterday
um I'm gonna try this in German so well
here Vogel einbein
okay
you can Applause yeah yes thank you
thank you
[Applause]
awesome but I'm here today to tell you
about
the features we launched in Cloud
functions and Cloud run
I'll do some live demos I mean what can
go wrong let's get started with Cloud
functions Cloud functions are the
easiest way to run some code on Google
cloud and extend Google Cloud products
all you need to do is write a function
and deploy you don't need any experience
and you can connect over 125 Google
cloud and third-party services
so this is when Cloud functions is
useful if you want to respond to events
if you want to respond and I want to
transform data as it arrives and store
it in a data store or and this is my
personal favorite if you want to extend
Google Cloud products so if you have
some logic in Java put it in a cloud
function and call it from a SQL query in
bigquery
what's new in Cloud functions
you told us you really liked Cloud
functions but you wanted more and that's
why we added more we launched the second
generation of cloud functions it has
more compute power longer processing
times and more advanced
so today you can select up to eight CPUs
and 32 gigabytes of RAM
this is about enabling workloads that
didn't fit on a cloud function in the
past and this also helps we increase the
maximum processing time for HTTP
triggered functions
to one hour a full hour
and finally more events Cloud functions
now supports over 125 event sources
through its integration with event Arc
that's more 10 times more than before so
Cloud functions second generation is
about more compute power longer
processing times and more event
but there's more
do you know that sinking feeling when
you've rolled out the change to
production you discover that you made a
mistake
like I know I do
um I I pushed a small change that didn't
need testing straight to production
I I will I will that maybe that this is
not the time and place to tell you about
that but um
second generation Cloud functions run on
cloud run
I know right that's that sounds
complicated but it has been this way all
along
so Cloud run and Cloud functions run on
the same shared infrastructure but we've
now made it even more explicit that
means you can click through and edit the
underlying Cloud run service and that
includes traffic management to the
revisions the cloud run automatically
creates for every deployment
and that's super useful because
sometimes you make an honest mistake and
you want to quickly quickly revert like
I did back in 2016.
um
still not a year
now here comes my favorite feature I
really like how you can use cloud
functions to extend other Cloud Google
Cloud products bigquery remote functions
lets you call a cloud function from a
SQL query
in case you're not familiar bigquery is
the the the data the serverless data
warehouse in Google Cloud
and with remote functions you can extend
bigquery with code written in Java
python JavaScript or any of the seven
supported languages and Cloud functions
and that's great for logic that's very
easy to express in a general programming
language but very hard to express using
SQL
let's say you're migrating from Hadoop
to bigquery and you have some logic
that's implemented in Java and you don't
want to prioritize moving it over to SQL
just now or maybe never with remote
functions you put that Java code in a
cloud function and you're good to go
time for a demo
there we go so I created a cloud
function
it's barely readable but I promise that
I'm calling the Google Maps API here to
get the distance between two cities so
let's let's show how that works let's
let's
look at my trip back home
so I enter Munich and Amsterdam it
generates this command for me oh I can
click the button testing Cloud here
oh no reconnect live damage you gotta
love him
click the button again
enter
so authorized of course yes
my trip back home will take 8 hours and
25 minutes
so now I can call this function from
bigquery so I have this query
I'll zoom in a bit for you so from
Munich to Amsterdam Paris Rome Stuttgart
and garching which is this very famous
city nearby
no people from cartoon in this in the
room that's sad it's 22 minutes away
so there you go
um back to the slides please
so that was Cloud functions
back to the slides please
yes thank you so that was Cloud
functions to wrap up we launched the
second generation and it's more longer
more more compute power longer
processing times and more events and an
improved integration with the rest of
Google Cloud now let's talk about Cloud
run
Cloud run is a fully managed platform
that lets you run your code in
containers
directly on top of Google's
infrastructure there's no kubernetes in
between Cloud run runs containers
directly on top of Google's
infrastructure and Club run
automatically adds more instances to
handle all incoming requests or events
it's very simple and automated
there's no infrastructure to manage no
cluster to worry about it allows you to
go faster to be more productive
let me put it this way we've
intentionally designed Cloud run
to make developers more productive
and today Cloud run is in Avail is
available in all 34 Google Cloud regions
and in every new Google Cloud region
we've announced Austria yesterday which
is nearby right
hmm us yeah yeah
um in every new Google Cloud region we
turn on cloud run is available from the
gut go
now when when do you use cloud run
services for websites and web
applications use your favorite stack to
build your application using any
programming language access your SQL
database render then Dynamic HTML Pages
you can also use streaming with
websockets it's all included
second is apis and microservices so you
can build a rest API a graphql API or
private microservices that communicate
over HTTP or grpc
and streaming data processing is a very
strong use case Club run Services can
receive messages from Pub sub and events
from event Arc
so this year
we launched Cloud run jobs
and you can think of that as a Quran for
the cloud so a job executes containers
to completion you can start a job using
the API the Google Cloud console or you
can schedule a recurring job and just as
with Services you only pay for the
resources these containers use while
they're running and there's no
infrastructure to manage
so to sum up you can use cloud run jobs
to run a script that performs database
migrations or other operational tasks to
run a scheduled job
think run job or to perform batch data
processing because Cloud run jobs also
supports parallel processing
so it's time for a demo now
there we go I will authorize
so
um this is my shell script hey it's
great to have you here it will just Echo
a line in the in reality it will do
something with gcloud or connect with my
database my favorite fruit of the day is
Apple
well that's funny my favorite food is
Apple
Apple
okay good I will save that
and I'll put it in a container so I have
this Docker file from Ubuntu add an
entry entry point script which is the
script I just added it and set that as
the entry point I will just build that
into a container with
Cloud builds
invalid source
[Music]
got it I'm in the wrong directory
and now I execute this command again
Okay so
huh
this is this is what happens with live
demos I like it
New Shell this should be
glad to change to a different yes this
will work
there we go okay so this should take 18
seconds
we'll have to be patient
if you know a fun joke tell me I can
share it with the rest
no takers
so it uploaded the source it's building
the the docker image using Cloud build
it's pushing the image
so now
when it's done I can go over to jobs I
click create new job
select the container image
the latest one you can see I tested this
many times it can't go wrong
I give it a name and I execute the job
immediately so this is one of those
three ways to start a job API Google
Cloud console
or you can also schedule it using Cloud
scheduler
and it's already executing
so when it finishes I will switch to the
log step and I will see my favorite
fruit
very exciting demo watching the spinner
hey it's great to have you here my
favorite food is Apple
thank you
I think it's really great when you like
when you like clap when I when I
actually finish my demo uh back to the
slides please
so in the title of this talk I promised
you seven new features in Cloud run and
before I dive in here's what I'll cover
datadoc integration health checks
CPU boost software delivery Shield
you've been hearing a lot about that
today security recommendations and Cloud
deploy and Integrations so I cheated a
bit because the last one Integrations is
actually two features
first we're proud to announce a
partnership with datadog around
observability so you can use the
official datadog in container agent to
send logs traces and metrics to datadoc
feature number two we are introducing
health checks on cloud run and to
understand what those are let's look at
the life cycle of a container so there's
the startup phase when your containers
are getting ready to serve requests and
there's the serving phase when it
actually serves requests
so when does a container transition from
starting to serving anyone knows
it uses a TCP startup probe so as soon
as your container listens on a TCP port
bam it starts to serve requests
with Cloud run health checks you can
customize the probe so in addition to
TCP you can now configure an HTTP probe
and this is useful for apps that start
listening on a TCP Port before they are
actually ready to serve requests
looking at your Big Spring boots app
um we're also introducing a new kind of
probe liveness probes aliveness probe
determines if a container is still able
to serve requests if it's not it will be
shut down and Cloud run starts a new
container
so you can use liveness probes to stop
container instances that got into a
corrupt local state or force a restart
after a certain amount of time
feature number three is startup CPU
boost and it helps
improve scaling speed so as you know
Cloud run automatically adds container
instances to handle all incoming
requests that's called Auto scaling and
container startups time is very
important when it comes to scaling So
the faster a container instance becomes
available the faster it can handle
requests
and the faster Cloud run can scale your
service
so to improve your container startup
time you can do one of two things
the first thing is well change your code
to create your container startup time
maybe you start lazy loading
dependencies maybe you try to remove
things that is auto loading so it starts
at faster
and the second thing you can do is well
configure more CPU because usually that
improves the startup time especially
when you're using one or two CPUs that
sounds great right
you pay more and and it starts and it
starts faster and you don't have to make
any code changes
yeah but it's also more expensive so
that's why we've came up with startup
boost
with CPU boost we dynamically double the
number of CPUs we allocate to a
container instance
during startup only
so as soon as the container finishes
startup we reduce the number of CPUs
again so you won't be charged for using
double the amount during the entire
container life cycle
and we've observed that this can almost
cut in half the startup of some
workloads for example when you use
spring boot with one or two CPUs
and I know I can see some faces in the
in the audience you won't believe me so
I will show you
I'm I'm a recovering Java developer so
let's go to My Demo
i i initialized a a spring boot app and
I deployed it to Cloud run
it's uh it's a fairly simple app all I
did was initialize it and added a
endpoint
that lets you admire my web design
skills it says hello Munich
um and I deployed it to Cloud run and it
now says that it starts in about
running jvm running for eight and a half
seconds 8.1 I also added an endpoint
that let me stop the container because
well makes it makes it better to collect
demo information
um about eight seconds so I can go into
edit and deploy new revision
and turn on
startup CPU boost and deploy it again so
that will take some time and we'll need
to collect the logs again so I have
deployed the same exact container image
and this other service that I've called
spring boost
uh it was funny I thought it was funny
anyway but this one starts in almost
half the time so it's four seconds four
and a half seconds for the day so this
one will scale faster and I won't
pay much more
so that's good let's go back to the
slides
let's go back to the slides for feature
number four
can we go back to the slide please
software delivery issued the security of
the software supply chain is top of mind
today and that's why we've enriched the
built-in security panel with the
software delivery Shield it shows
security information
um for example the salsa level of your
container so salsa is an acronym and
stands for supply chain levels for
software artifacts it defines a level of
assurance for your workload so if you
automatically build from your git
repository using Cloud build you will be
already on level two as Cloud build
captures Source provenance and it signs
artifacts by default
and additionally
it displays vulnerabilities that were
found in your deployed container image
grouped by severity
but we're doing more to help you secure
your Cloud run service we've added two
new security recommendations with active
assist
active assist scans the configuration of
your Cloud run service and it looks for
well recommendations to make and it will
now suggest to use secret manager if it
detects that your environment variables
might contain API keys or passwords so
if you have an environment fireable at
SAS API key or it's SAS password well so
now maybe you want to use secret manager
click here to enable
I think that's pretty cool it also
recommends to use the built-in service
identity if it then if it detects it you
might be storing those basket long-term
service account credentials as a file
inside of your container image I hope
you're not doing that but if you do
Cloud run will tell you
feature number six Cloud deploy is a
fully managed continuous delivery
solution and it lets you manage the
release of your container in a pipeline
so with Cloud builds it was a bit of a
manual work to get that all working so
with Cloud builds Cloud deploy you can
manage that from developer environments
to staging to Productions to production
and it now has direct support for cloud
run
finally Integrations
I've said this before Cloud run has been
intentionally designed to make
developers more productive
and we're constantly looking for ways to
improve that so one of those
opportunities is to reduce
the amount of manual steps you have to
do with automation so here are two
examples of common tasks that require a
lot of steps to do with Cloud run today
creating a cloud memory store instance
and connecting it to the cloud run
service because you have to add this
serverless VPC connector wire through
the IP to the cloud service etc etc
uh the second thing is setting up with
the global external https load bouncer
in front of your Cloud run service with
a custom domain right because that lets
you take advantage of cloud DNA cloud
CDN and Cloud armor
enable easier migrations
both tasks are not hard or complex but
they do require a lot of manual work you
have to read the docs follow a long list
of steps make sure not to click on the
wrong button so Cloud run Integrations
is like that robot that does all the
work for you
it's hard to create a memory instance
and bind it to your service and it does
that for you
so look if you forgot anything else from
what I told you today I hope you're
remembering the amazing dad jokes
remember this one thing
we've intentionally designed Club run to
make developers more productive and
we're looking to improve that every
single day
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]